and you start to make compromises uh
because you need people to do the work
to hit those deadlines that you've
established that is the genesis of
mistakes
um you need to hold out until you have
the top people aim for the top people if
you can't get them immediately
understand what it would take to get
them
right and orient orient around that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
this is a story that's really worth
hearing
meet barack rabinowitz managing partner
of f2 venture capital
previously barack was a partner at
genesis partners where he focused on
early stage investment opportunities and
the junction
seed investment program prior to genesis
partners
brock led three startups in the uk and
israel as co-founder and ceo
including mytopia acquired by 888
holdings and supported numerous
successful technology companies as an
angel investor
barack obama how you doing i'm good
thank you thank you for
inviting me to the beautiful f2 of
course it's amazing the view here is
spectacular nobody can see but
i'm looking directly at yeah at the
beautiful landscape of tel aviv
and we're not talking here about telly
we're talking investing and
barak you've created here one of the top
vc's in israel
all day long just keep hearing about f2
yeah from founders from the
from pres everything it's amazing what
you've built here and before we get to
that i want to hear a little bit about
you
so coming from ohio harvard now tel aviv
did you know back in ohio that you're
gonna build an
amazing vc here in israel no was that a
grand plan
no no and and i i you know grew up in
ohio
really a public school um
used to hang out in the parking lot of
mcdonald's and uh
i just had a vision that i wanted to be
in the
sort of front of a movement to have some
impact
but i had no idea what where i mean i
traded baseball cards but didn't even
watch baseball so it was more
um there were some uh um
inherent things i enjoyed like like
trading like tracking value
like identifying winners uh that that's
looking back
looking for the themes but uh
i went to college you know i applied to
several schools and
never thought i'd end up where i did
georgetown university it's a catholic
school
jesuit institution and i'm a jewish boy
from ohio but
someone had a spare application on their
floor and i filled it out so
you know i could i could sit here now
and try to draw a logical path but a lot
of times it's just following your heart
and seeing where where you end up so
what was the point for you
looking back you say i think i like this
this ecosystem i think i'm gonna find
myself
where i'm where you are today well i
you know think a lot about life and
happiness and the point of it all and uh
one of the things i realized is there's
a few things in your life you can do to
make a step change in your happiness
level
one of them is picking the right partner
another is picking
where you live and i thought to myself i
used to love coming here on vacation
more than anywhere else
and if i can actually live here and work
here
in the place that i love well i bet that
will make me happier and it does
and it's because all of us here carry
with us
i think for the most part a sense that
we're we're part of something oh yeah
100 and so you come here in 2002 yeah
and this is after
the this is after harvard right no i
i was in banking kind of losing my soul
and wall street and i saw first of all
9 11 happened yeah and my bank was
impacted
it was the biggest tenant of the world
trade center i wasn't in that office but
still we were impacted and my bank and
goldman sachs decided to
create a non-profit to help the victims
specifically
who were widows because their husbands
were in finance and managed all the
money
the widows were left to make order out
of the chaos
and the government was paying them out
through a victim compensation program a
million dollars on average
and they became vulnerable to all kinds
of sharks out there
so we created a financial advice program
and that was actually my first startup i
was
the analyst from morgan stanley and
there was an analyst from goldman and we
came together under a chairman of
goldman and did this for six months
i couldn't go back to banking after that
right so during that time i saw morgan
stanley's opening in office in israel
and
a gentleman named yair cerrusi is
leading the effort and i i read that on
bloomberg
and i contacted him and said i gotta
come out and it was second
intifada and he said listen if you're
crazy enough to come out here now
we'll have you wow so that's what
brought me
to israel that sense of adventure and
connection with my roots
craziness craziness yeah uh
i did that for a year met my partner
jonathan sachs who were partners now in
f2
also was impacted by the intifada in the
sense that from our building on
harbaugh street right across the street
from where we're sitting now
i could hear the buses blowing up really
and i was also 24 at the time and wow i
always
had a dream to serve in the army and my
dad had served here in the six day war
and i felt such pride when i looked at
his photos
and as a son of an israeli i could be
here for a year but if i stayed longer
i'd be required to do military
but if i did that i'd only serve three
months in schlafbert which isn't very
meaningful
so i realize all those things together i
should volunteer
to serve in a combat unit um and that's
what i did i left the bank and joined
the
24. yeah i was 25 when i went in yeah
we'll talk about a few years but what
was that like this is crazy
again that sense of impact like uh
banking is so superficial so
i went into the knack and i was
so happy i mean no no tie no
suit
everyone dressed the same you know
the elbo the
volunteers lonely soldiers are the most
motivated soldiers in the army and
that's why the army invests in them i
think
to set an example and i was definitely
the case
like living my dream and uh taking
photos of everything and writing about
it
wow yeah now how did the your fellow
soldiers i mean it's a very you know
yeah experience yeah how did they accept
you know coming from the us yeah from
banking
yeah all of a sudden you're in the
knockout well i was popular i was the
one soldier with some money so on the
weekends
everyone would come to my place big
parties you bought the oranges
yeah or actually i i took everyone the
brasserie on
a very fancy restaurant for for brunch
it was really fun um
as hot as it sounds during that time in
the army the training is very intense
and then
in deployment you have a lot of standing
still like eight hour guard duty shifts
and
i just did the gmat preparation and
essays in my head during that time to
stay awake
and i played the harvard and was
accepted so that's
amazing so harvard mba and and you're
coming back to israel
the story of f2 yeah
yeah that happened well uh
my best friend in the army was a belgian
guy he introduced me to a belgian
girl we started dating she was in london
i had to come to london
for her so we did a startup there was
bought
and then we decided to move to israel
and another startup
and i invested as an angel in a company
in the junction which is part of our
platform here at f2
after my company was acquired so i
joined johnny at
genesis partners which is one of the
original funds in israel from
25 years ago and took a lot of best
practices from there but
johnny and i thought we could direct
them to a clear gap in the market in
israel at the preceding seed stage
and that is the genesis of f2 the
genesis of f2
yeah you're sitting here and you're
thinking what are we in the ecosystem
and i'm hearing you already say
early stage which is you know when they
i'm guessing when the venture capital
scene started here yeah we didn't have
many players that are focusing on you
know the roots of
of where these yeah where these are
happening what is your conviction or
your thesis around the early stage
companies that you're
looking to work with in the next in the
next years
yeah um
look there's a general checklist
targeting large markets
very intelligent driven people authentic
entrepreneurs
um complementary team and skill sets
and some validation in the form of
people they worked with before
design partners and all the rest but it
does come down to just that intangible x
factor uh that you feel when you're
sitting in the room with these people
right and and so what i'm hearing from
you a lot of it is also just from
experience you've seen thousands of
companies by now
i'm guessing that you're you know the
intuition bug
is pretty strong yeah and and and the
theme here is failure is the best
teacher
and failure in my own startups failure
and not backing companies that went on
to be successful
um learning all the time from those
experiences so that you don't repeat it
in the sense that when you see something
that walks through the door that could
be big you rot
and that's what we do here we put
everything to the side
it's like a fire drill we work as a team
to show to the founders the value we can
bring and in parallel do our
work our diligence so that we can come
up with a term sheet very fast
how does this learning take place i'm
fascinated by this concept yeah
learning from failures learning from you
know i imagine myself you know hopefully
one day i'll get yeah so
where you know i have a fund and i'm
thinking okay if i miss a deal and i
know for example
a a fund in california that missed on
airbnb in their seed stage yeah
i'm trying to think and you know they're
really upset yeah now
looking back it doesn't how do you
actually learn from these experiences
something tangible that can push you
forward
one of the things you realize in vc is
it's the winners that count and the
losers are
irrelevant in the sense that yes we're
investing
2.5 million on average in every company
but when you hit an explorium
our investment explorium is worth more
than our entire first fund and we're
just getting started there
so it doesn't matter that i lost 2.5
million dollars on a company that we
wrote off
no it's completely irrelevant in other
words take the bet
if you see the spark take the bet we're
in the risk taking business we're a
small sliver of a total asset allocation
pie of our lps
and that is meant for high risk so you
have to orient yourself
um so you don't as i said make the same
mistakes of the past and you give
yourself
every opportunity to succeed in the
future so what i'm hearing from it's not
just
learning how to make better deals but
it's learning also to have the strength
and
the strong mentality of knowing to
buffer out the noise
and concentrate on what's really
important and beautiful
about the vc world yes right yes and so
this family that we're here yeah and
you've invited me to this office here
yeah
it feels a little bit different i have
to say i'm walking in the energy is
different people
are talking to each other very friendly
it's not that every person is in their
own cubicle
yeah what is sort of your explanation of
this or
you're interested what's happening here
you know for my startup days i i really
hated management
and the only way to solve that is to
have people who are self-driven
uh out to prove something and uh
obviously good people and that's what we
have here if a person comes in here it
needs to be managed
and they're just not going to last so we
have a collection of
individuals who are leaders and know
where they're heading and
and we all work together on a level
playing field
with a common value set of values which
we have on the door trust boldness and
efficiency
um so we all know on a macro level how
to navigate
right now you're also you know an
entrepreneur at heart
yeah is do you consider this
some form of a company that you run you
consider that
because you know this is not like
banking i'm guessing goldman sachs right
yeah
no 100 no this is our startup and now
we've we've you know we have one fund
and a second fund and we'll assume we'll
have a third fund
and and it's just like a startup how
you're you're climbing the ranks from c
to a to b to c um
i i think we've had a lot of success but
i take nothing for granted
and yes we've just closed a deal but i
have no idea
where the next deal is going to come
from or when it will hit and i just have
to remain
humble and and receptive right and so
you talked before about happiness and
yeah and happiness levels yeah how do
you raise the happiness level as
a vc where do you find the happiness
within this part of your life
um it it i mean first of all you need
that self-selecting team of people who
have that same core set of values so
you'll all be happy as a result of the
same things and a lot of that is seeing
our company succeed
bringing a key hire closing a growth
round
um winning a deal
we all on our whatsapp groups we have
multiple groups connecting our team
members all the time weekends nights
that's how you can see people are really
passionate about
it um
how i mean what what is life about if
not like i call it roi return on impact
that that's what we're looking for here
and what greater impact is there to be
at this
ground stage of future great companies
and future great leaders and layered
into that this sense of pride in israel
and these young israelis coming up and
making a
positive change in the world i can't
imagine a different scenario and
you know i love this job so much like i
come in on weekends i
there's no separation of work in life
and that's how i think i know i'm in the
right direction
it took me until i was close to 40 years
old to find this path
so i don't think i could have changed
anything all those failures led me here
um but i wish that for everyone
so now talking more to to young
entrepreneurs yeah
and i'm putting myself in the same boat
you know a lot of
you know a lot of really amazing
entrepreneurs that have the privilege of
having you on their board and you're
invested in
incredible companies like exploring
parametrics and yeah
really incredible incredible companies
to the other thousands of young
entrepreneurs out there
yeah what have you learned working with
thousands you know looking at thousands
of companies
some some things that maybe not trivial
that young entrepreneur may
conform to because of the because of the
stress
and and the society things that now you
understand that you know
we can really understand ourselves and
it will make our life better or make our
path better
well um
yeah i think that uh it's key to have
great people around you and um what
happens is you raise money and then you
have pressure to release a product on
time and it's a concrete timeline that
you
promised to your investors and how
you're going to do that without people
you start to hire people and you realize
this guy has this issue this woman has
this issue
and you start to make compromises uh
because you need people to do the work
to hit those deadlines that you've
established that is the genesis of
mistakes
um you need to hold out until you have
the top people aim for the top people
if you can't get them immediately
understand what it would take to get
them right and
orient orient around that and that's why
we put such a heavy focus here on people
that's why my partner is ahead
is a psychologist if you get that right
the rest should follow
right now you've been in the ecosystem
for a long time yeah genesis being one
of the
you know the early and amazing funds
that we all know about and read about
yeah you're observing the israeli
ecosystem
what do you find here in the last few
decades what have you been observing
either change or some of the beautiful
or challenging aspects of it
maybe people from around the world don't
necessarily truly understand
what is this startup or scale of nation
well i think
it's important to understand the source
of the innovation and
i think it goes back all the way to the
hostile region we live in
and the necessity for a big military and
a
mandatory national service men women
irrespective
of socioeconomic backgrounds skill will
you know scan for certain traits and
those who have a potential to be
technologists grouped together and given
highly ambitious tasks and told the the
fate of the country rests on their
shoulder
and that creates very systematic waves
of entrepreneurs coming out
of the military tackling the biggest
problems in ai and cyber security and
connectivity and other sectors
that can't be replicated there cannot be
a hub like this anywhere else
so that's one the the key trait they
share in addition to innovation and
and curiosity is resilience
um so that we're used to every five
years having some sort of conflict here
and we can withstand that and
actually adapt very quickly and faster
than the rest of the world
but on the negative side there is a big
difference between the last generation
of israelis and the current generation
coming up in the sense that i feel the
current generation may take some things
for granted i was going to ask you about
that
yeah and what why do you think that is
um i mean i i it always surprises
israelis when i tell them i've
experienced anti-semitism
they don't even know what that is like
it's a it's in a textbook but growing up
in ohio as a minority you experience it
all the way through
um and that creates a certain humility
and
uh also a calibration like the u.s
is so much bigger than israel and
everyone
here talks about doing something special
but
unless they spend time outside of israel
they they may be
setting their sides too low or ignorant
of certain challenges or whatnot so
people need to get out
and experience the world thank you for
inviting me here my pleasure wonderful
and we talked a lot about investing i
want to ask a few more questions about
yourself
sure and they're weird but but they're
important to me yeah
yeah back to middle school in ohio yeah
what's your favorite subject that you
had definitely history really
yeah any specific time in history i mean
now i read uh
nothing but historical fiction from like
1900 to 1930 and for some reason that
rain maybe i'm reincarnated from someone
at that time but that's
just when all the world was changing
you know the birth of aviation
automobiles uh
telephones electricity it all happened
then
right and yet if you can you can read
and learn from there
without having the stress or anxiety
that you do of reading about
modern leaders like elon musk because
there the temptation is to compare
yourself to elon musk
but if you're reading about thomas
edison he's dead and gone you can just
take the lessons learned without the
anxiety
i i i love that in this world
yeah somebody that and i'm sure there
are many but somebody that would serve
as an inspiration
for you or some sort of role model in in
any capacity professional personal
yeah i like to give the example of rocky
balboa he's a fictional character but
uh i i you know his motto is
his whole life was a million to one shot
it just inspires me deeply and the whole
story of how sylvester stallone wrote
that he was a
sort of b great actor and witnessed the
fight of muhammad ali
late in his career and a
challenge by someone who actually his
whole goal was just to go the distance
with ali and he did
and stallone wrote that movie in about
four days
and then he insisted to play the role of
the star himself
even though the uh mgm at the time told
him they weren't gonna pick it up they
wanted to put a different actor and he
insisted
it's a wonderful story and the beauty of
having fictional heroes is they can't
let you down
i love it three words that you would use
to describe yourself
that you would use them yeah i think
optimistic yeah
um sense that in the short 20 minutes
that we have here
yeah um
humble and uh
curious thank you very very much
[Music]